ok next game with this mutual slump what
opening cannot try on let's go for the
set up again with e5 I didn't get any
bad positions yet I guess and our people
just take on you five surprisingly
yeah yeah yeahs really surprising okay
no idea this looks like a decent move
always at least with the light on e to
it doesn't apply any pressure only five
maybe I can use this diagonal
yeah I need to a five to secure c-54 my
pieces and also at some point it can be
problematic for y2 to put these pawns on
a for any form often obviously not in
the near future that done I've seen it
happen so what now g58 an idea g5 and
night h5 I could I could try this
trying to get the bishop or to put some
put the night on f4 oh just this this is
a welcome move of course he doesn't try
to fight a fight 45 you can play g3 of
course there is some possibility to to
play against this
it's not terribly terribly dangerous if
you place it but I'd like to prevent it
nonetheless I could I could just play
Bishop e3 to keep the structure intact
and also of course one to keep the
Knights bone okay so now this is just a
fine position I've got the great night
only five and lots of end games are
already on pretty good for me for
instance if we exchange all rocks that i
can simply press but i don't want to
allow i don't want my king back here is
it a problem well i still have them all
the way to to the Queen side
yeah I don't see how I can make progress
without this ok so the next step would
be to get the King to c5 and then to be
4d for and then try to advance on the
queenside yeah he wants to play c3 which
is decent i guess doesn't place you
three ok yeah this is this is very very
nice position now maybe even King before
why not
so big question now be five or not I try
to make a pass porn so the play a form
he might take and place III
yeah time warning that doesn't give much
maybe I need to try some some other
approach I try to get the bishop to c6
first try to regroup my pieces a bit you
phone now
so interesting now maybe I can just take
and play play the bishop here he has to
go night to f2 I know not just my upon
that bone is going through white resides
yeah yeah I needed to play King be one
then and I would try to invade the Kings
side with the King I think this is this
would be winning as well should be
should be yeah I just I just got over
with the king yeah the only problem was
there was a time again position was very
fine from you all the way he made many
really helpful helpful moves especially
putting everything on white and not
fighting for for the black squares which
I completely terminated